[Music]
earlier this week it was announced that
in an upcoming dc comic the new superman
will come out as bisexual and people are
losing their [ __ ] we will explore this
now in a segment called [ __ ] please
[Music]
[ __ ] please
y'all really upset that the new superman
will be bisexual he is a fictional
character he's not even the original
superman that's superman's son
why can't he be his authentic self are
you afraid him and lex luthor are gonna
trick you into a threesome you wish
look how handsome these men are you
could never now some people are saying
this is ruining my childhood [ __ ]
please
a comic book character being bisexual
ruined your childhood your childhood was
trash to begin with
that's right
let it get ruined instead of being
fixated on superman's son maybe you
should focus on things that are
happening in the real world like school
shootings anti-massacres and
anti-vaxxers because they are literally
ruining childhoods also superman is an
alien from an alien planet humans are a
whole other species to him and you're
okay with his inter-species love affair
with lois lane but his son can't get his
groove on with a male reporter [ __ ]
please
lastly for those of you who are saying
there's a queer agenda or they're
shoving their lifestyle down our throats
i would like to say to you with all of
the power of my ancestors behind me
[ __ ] please
it is called representation so please go
outside and to the left with that
foolishness there is a child out there
who is scared and not feeling seen and
they don't see themselves represented on
tv and they can be made to feel like
they are lesser because of who they are
one day that child is going to pick up a
comic book and see an iconic character
that's associated with strength honesty
and america and they're gonna see that
that person is just like them and that
it is okay for them to be who they are
and it will change their life that is
why it is so important that we have
queer comic book characters because the
only queer agenda is living an open and
happy life oh and saving the world from
upcoming meteors yeah this has been
[ __ ] please
[Music]
you